i
wear a mask to school
i wear a mask to school
hi ho the derry-o why we're a mask to
school
it helps to keep me safe
hi ho the derry-o it helps to keep me
safe just notice a couple things about
this video first kid bottom left corner
where's the mask gotcha under his nose
isn't it yeah that's not gonna be super
effective virtually all of these masks
are cloth correct there's like one kid
here wearing a surgical mask the
surgical mask doesn't interface properly
because it's an adult surgical mask
there's been widespread data on whether
masking small children in schools is
conducive to actually preventing spread
of the disease the answer is at best
inconclusive the number of children who
are dying from covet is exorbitantly low
very very very low thank god to pretend
that it is the mask that is keeping them
safe rather than you know their youth is
of course to ignore all possible data